I was at a meeting with members of the
radiations and with the meeting started
at 10 o clock and we got the news at
10:15 but we were asked not to announce
it before 11 o'clock when the official
announcements would be made by the Nobel
Peace Prize Institute so this was really
something very special and I was really
you know looking forward to an asset
service while the meeting was going on
so finally I asked the chairperson to
give a break of 15-20 minutes or 11:00
and I went to my office to prepare a
statement for announcement to give the
good news to all member countries and
when I came back there was an applause
so everybody learned about it through
the news of course during that break it
was all over so that's that's was
fantastic